in this continuing, almost never ending saga of
trying to get covid relief passed. Joe Biden has
negotiated not with Republicans, but with more
moderate Democrats to further restrict who is
eligible for a stimulus check. What if you're
wondering, great, now that they've negotiated,
which Republicans are going to support the bill
as a result of the negotiation? The answer is, I'm
not aware of any. This is Democrats negotiating
with Democrats to weaken covid stimulus just to
get it passed. And either way, it doesn't appear
as though Republicans are going to support this.
Now, I know that there are people in my audience
who will be mad for this critique. But come on,
guys, 2000 now, I mean, I'm going to get
to the pragmatic piece, so just let me
let me work through it. OK, here's the just
disgusting, frustrating part of all of this.
Two thousand dollars became fourteen hundred. And
when I critique that, some people wrote to me and
said, David, it was obvious from the beginning
Joe Biden meant we would add fourteen hundred to
the six hundred to make it 2000. That's not a fair
critique. You're doing a bad critique, David. OK,
then I say, well, Joe Biden said it would pass
right away and it didn't pass right away. It's
March and I critique that. And some people wrote
to me and said, David, you know, you should have
known that when a president says right away,
they don't mean right away. They mean months. OK,
and now to get the fourteen hundred dollar check,
the checks are going to phase out more quickly as
income goes up. So here is the changes that were
made under the old plan passed by the House.
You get fourteen hundred dollars if your
income is up to seventy five thousand
and it starts phasing down to zero once
your income is one hundred thousand
under the new plan, it's just more restrictive.
The fourteen hundred starts phasing out and
it goes to zero at 80 grand instead of at one
hundred grand. So in short, in the House version,
anyone making over one hundred thousand gets
zero in the Senate version that was negotiated
yesterday between Biden and Senate Republicans,
anyone earning over eighty thousand dollars a year
gets zero. Now, do I think that this is a
really dumb negotiation? Yes, the phase out
at one hundred thousand dollars was fine. But the
reality is with a 50 50 majority in the Senate,
50/50 with Comilla, as the deciding vote enties,
Democrats can't afford to lose a single vote.
So Joe Manchin now has power. Jeanne Shaheen,
a Democrat from New Hampshire who also wanted
to restrict the checks. She has power. She wants
to take the money saved by dropping the limit and
send that money to hospitals. OK, does it still
make sense to pass this bill? It does. In addition
to the stimulus checks, the bill has three
hundred and fifty billion dollars for states.
One hundred and thirty billion dollars for opening
schools. One hundred and sixty billion dollars for
vaccinations and tax testing and enhanced child
tax credit rental assistance, food assistance. So
it's important to pass this regardless and
we can't keep delaying it. But is this a
really lame negotiation where it's Democrats
negotiating with Democrats and either way,
Republicans won't support it? Of course
it is. At some point we have to recognize,
even though there are Democrats there, they're
very moderate. Some, we would even say are almost
sort of like centrist Republicans, people like
Joe Manchin. It's just the reality. And it's
not even that. I think it's that important that
people earning ninety eight thousand dollars get
a check. Like it's more the idea that we have
zero Republicans on board. It's an emergency to
pass this. And Democrats are negotiating
with each other over whether the cutoff
should be 80 grand or 100 grand. It's sort of
like a what are we doing here type of moment.
I get that if you make ninety eight thousand
dollars, you make fourteen hundred bucks and like
five or six days of work. This is less about that.
It's the big picture of absurdity of how it hasn't
even nearly been only because of Republicans
that this hasn't passed. And of course,
the 15 dollar minimum wage is just gone from the
bill altogether. But we've already covered that
and we knew it now on the on the minimum wage.
I'm getting some emails, which I support. OK,
I'm getting emails from people saying, David, you
know, the Senate parliamentarian who decided you
can't do the 15 dollar minimum wage in this bill.
The Senate parliamentarian can just be overruled.
It's not you know, people are acting like,
oh, it would be a massive step to overrule
the Senate parliamentarian. OK, yeah, it would
or it wouldn't. But the truth is, if you overrule
the Senate parliamentarian and you include a 15
dollar minimum wage in the covid relief bill,
I just don't think it passes. I don't think Joe
Manchin votes for the bill. And you can't afford
to lose a single vote in the Senate right now,
given that no Republicans plan to vote for it. So
I'm just as disgusted as you are by what's going
on. Don't don't mistake this for me, not being
disgusted in a practical reality. They're just
not going to vote for it. If it's in the bill,
it's not going to pass, even if you override the
Senate parliamentarian and put it in the bill.
It's not going to get passed. Now, you could make
the argument and I know some in my audience will,
that it's worth it and it's worth it. Not passing
to get those Democratic senators on the record
saying they're against it. They're already
on the record. They've said it in interviews.
They've they've put statements out. So you're
just slowing down, getting money to anybody.
And but bottom line is, we've been
talking about since November 4th,
even with the two Georgia Senate seats
that Democrats took from Republicans,
you still need to convince Joe Manchin that wasn't
an understatement. That wasn't just something I
said for fun. It's Joe Manchin and it's Jeanne
Shaheen. And over the next couple of years, it'll
be one or two other Democratic senators as well.
The answer is we have to flip more seats saying
primary. Joe Manchin in West Virginia. If you run
Bernie in West Virginia against Joe Manchin and
somehow Bernie wins the primary, then a Republican
wins that seat. The answer isn't to to I mean,
listen, primary Joe Manchin, if you want. I'm
not saying don't, but the solution here is you
need more than a 50 50 majority. And then, you
know, we get to the question of is this the last
and final covid stimulus? Our friend, Congressman
Rokan last week on the show said he doesn't
think it should be the final stimulus. I would
love to not need another coronavirus stimulus
that's going to be determined by how quickly cases
decline, how quickly vaccinations increase. I'm
not seeing an appetite for more stimulus after
this bill is done at the Congress level, although
some individual members of the House and Senate
do want more stimulus, this may actually be it.
And it would be great if nothing else was needed.
But that's just it remains a question mark. Send
me your thoughts about all of this negotiation.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,